[Music]
this is my daily point of entrance
to the new college garden which i've had
the honour
of running as garden fellow for the past
40 years
i come every day through the quadrangle
here
and i have a sense that the garden and
the flowers are waiting
to delight me puzzle me and test me
every morning this is an extraordinary
time to see the garden
there's nobody else here and that's
never normally the case
every warm afternoon in the summer the
glass is covered with people
reading books drinking coffee or kissing
and my garden here is in dialogue with
other people
so to see it with none of them is like a
duet with one part missing
but i want the chance to pass on what i
have tried to realize
and the principles behind the planting
and what you see
so that you can think them over adapt
them
i hope improve them but at least
have a starting point
gardens are edited and selected nature
and in my view they often improve on
nature
if you left this garden simply to go
wild
it would be full of ground elder and
bindweed which are extraordinarily
boring
but because i can edit it i have blue
bindweed with that wonderful morning
glory flowers
on the railings behind me i used to grow
one called split personality thinking it
was
true to several of the professors in the
college but i've decided that heavenly
blue
the great blue i premiere morning glory
is the really beautiful one
and it looks like a framed stained glass
window or a sketch by bern
jones in early october when for the
first time
and we hope this year too the
undergraduates come to begin
their thinking careers
the long border is one of the main
glories of the garden
now there are two principles to
herbaceous borders
one was enunciated by the great miss
jekyll
that you should plant in narrow strips
and you should grade the colors
softly leading from yellow to orange to
red
to down again to pink and so on
following
the famous system of a color wheel in
the 1850s
but i don't do that here i'm thinking of
uh dramatic changes of color and i think
of it
like a very good lunch with the ft
we're talking here about five courses
one after the other
but on each separate course i'm trying
to have something that is repeated
down the length of the border that draws
your eye
right down the huge long run and vista
you can enjoy when looking down it
most of the plants here attach
poignantly
to my life biography to friends who
first showed me them
to places i first found them but here
that dark purple dahlia is admiral
rawlings
which an ft reader sent to me
unsolicited
through the post about 22 years ago and
i opened it and thought i just don't
want
another dahlia how wrong you can be she
said it was fabulous
and it is there are so many other small
examples that i really treasure so when
i walk down the border i try to look at
the hole
i look at the interrelationships i see
the invisible people
and their work finding the plants
sometimes giving them to me sometimes
talking
to me here i see past faces past
incidents
past pupils i remember who loved this
that or the other
whereas you i hope see a blend of colors
much has been written about more natural
informal
wilder gardening looking more like a
prairie where plants
interrelate naturally and aren't in a
what i call
euro gardening so about four years ago i
thought i would try some of it here
and it is more open and more apparently
wild of course it's still
very artificial like all gardening i'm
pleased with the front row at this time
of the year
those are three types of low-growing
basically asta
which anyone watching could have that
within two years
they grow beautifully and they make
informal groups
with the big californian tree poppy that
at this time of the year is running wild
but it's absolutely untrue that this
style of gardening
is less laborious than our big
herbaceous borders
we spend more time keeping this tidy
than we ever do
on our big traditional beds
fashion is for those who have no style
so i ignore it i go my own way
i'm aware what's going on and i go on
learning
you don't need great rarities what you
need
are really good varieties of first class
families
and for that you have to look travel
read and form your own taste
plow your own furrow go your own way
and stick with your own changing and
developing
style it's never ending but gardens
never ever stand still you must prepare
for change and for a constant process
it's a way of life that's why i love it